[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi 7 octobre voici
les titres de cette édition
c'est en ce moment la fête de la science
l'événement national fête cette année
ses 30 ans dans cette édition
l'interview de young park cet ex
chercheuse de l'inra et à jouy en josas
est l'une des lauréates du prix l'oréal
unesco focus également sur le programme
de la fête de la science à
l'observatoire de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines suite et fin de
notre dossier de la rédaction consacré
cette semaine à france relance le plan
de 100 milliards d'euros a pu bénéficier
aussi aux collectivités exemple à
chevreuse qui profitent de l'envelope du
gouvernement pour faire son éclairage
public et puis c'est un classique de
l'automne à buc le 28e festival de la
bande dessinée se tient ce week end au
château de la commune en attendant ce
rendez-vous le scénariste et réalisateur
de yakari et xavier giacometti animait
un atelier auprès d'enfants c'était à
viroflay
les gimontois avant le premier tour de
l'élection municipale partielle à
trappes quatre candidats sont en lice et
focus ce soir sur la candidature de luc
liseret tête de liste de trappes à
gauche
[Musique]
marie curie catherine johnson ou encore
to you par leurs découvertes et leurs
travail scientifique ces femmes ont
changé notre monde pourtant aujourd'hui
moins de 30% de chercheurs à l'échelle
mondiale sont des femmes pour les
encourager à poursuivre leur carrière le
prix jeune talent l'oréal unesco
récompense ces femmes en leur octroyant
une bourse de 15 mille euros l'édition
2000 21 s'est déroulée ce jeudi en ces
temps de fête de la science est parmi
les trente cinq lauréates et youtube par
qui a officié à l'inra à jouy en josas
son interview par céline charles
[Musique]
oui une crise et aux agrumes tout
continue d avoir une taille en symbole
vivant
comme des parcs ou
si je dois être honnête ruiz à la tipp
pour des espaces travailleuse et sans
escale à jet tours visite a drug stores
ou encore la brionne à versailles où
steve wallace retour aux peines sévères
comprend sénateurs construit
[Musique]
lakers which can be used ml de lait
auprès des jeunes so by qualité ou de
matériel
now you dig in our life is coming
matériaux électriques anodin mais qui
confondent hommage organisé un week ends
aux mecs et de marc amoudry flandre et
production du stand by me corgan
[Musique]
umar aman
païens et bravo à youtube pas pour ce
prix et je vous disais une remise de
prix ce matin à l'occasion en ce moment
de cette fête de la science est
d'ailleurs l'université versailles saint
quentin en yvelines se joint à
l'événement avec des animations et
rendez vous c'est jusqu'au 11 octobre
alors est ce qu d'ailleurs lui aussi
beaucoup de choses au programme global
l'observatoire de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines on en parle avec
annabelle doazit kate avec mon plateau
bonsoir chargé de communication à l'eau
vs q quelles sont déjà des objectifs de
l'événement qui fête cette année ses 30
ans l'objectif de l'événement c'est de
montrer un petit peu qu'est la science
montre et le métier aussi de
scientifiques
peut-être de susciter des vocations
d'échangés aussi je crois que c'est très
important de manière un petit peu
ludique avec des choses qu'on fait pas
forcément dans son quotidien de montrer
que la science c'est accessible que le
métier là accessible aussi je crois que
c'est très important et tout ou presque
et sciences autour de nos finalement
donc c'est important aussi dans l'aisne
fait alors au programme alo dsq des
ateliers une journée portes ouvertes
également pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas l'observatoire il ya plusieurs
domaines de recherche le spatial
l'arctique également le climat ce sera
exactement on a trois la borne à quatre
laboratoires maintenant on a le latmos
qui travaillent plus citées sur des
questions spatiales qui travaillent sur
des missions d'envergure d'envergure
internationale on a le lc eux qui
travaillent sur toutes les questions
climatiques le cercle sur l'adaptation
des populations aux changements
climatiques en zone arctique et il ya
moins d'un an on a accueilli un nouveau
laboratoire qui s'appelle le l'imep et
qui travaille plus sur les aspects
géographique du club et est ce qu on le
rappelle qui est installé à guyancourt
mais par ses laboratoires rayonne aussi
sur un plus grand territoire alors cette
semaine jeudi l obs qu est bien organise
cette fête de la science y participent
en tout cas il ya déjà eu des ateliers
pour les scolaires vous avez accueilli
des classes
et jusqu'à demain soir on accueille les
scolaires on a à peu près cinq cent
cinquante élèves là en trois jours
depuis le cm1 jusqu'à la terminale et
donc le programme va se poursuivre
jusqu'à ce week-end avec aussi des
ateliers qui seront ouverts alors à tous
les enfants les 6 12 ans et c'est samedi
quels sont les types d'ateliers qui vont
être creusés samedi ce sont des ateliers
qui sont réservées aux 6-12 ans
uniquement c'est à dire qu'on ne garde
que les enfants de quoi les parents
pourtant le précieuse oui c'est ça il
reste encore quelques places d'ailleurs
si ça intéresse certains et certaines de
s'inscrire on est ouvert de 14 heures à
17 heures est donc là c'est vraiment
très calé puisqu'on a que les enfants on
propose plusieurs choses on a un atelier
qui s'appelle co2 mon amour qui
travaille sur les questions de co2 on a
un jeu numérique pour construire sa
propre fusée hélas cette année le ce
week-end exceptionnellement on accueille
un planétarium donc ça c'est un gros
événement on a fait un partenariat avec
l'association planète sciences voilà qui
nous voulons un planétarium c'est une
structure gonflable et là on est
vraiment dans un vrai planétarium ça va
vraiment un grand succès je pense un
atelier aussi également autour de lui
des excuses at ce nano satellites sur
lequel a travaillé le latmos on pourra
parler de cette thématique aussi de la
fête je suis tout à fait exactement
parler de l'actualité du vécu sat qui a
été donc envoyé en janvier dernier et
qui envoient régulièrement évidemment
des informations qui passe au dessus de
nos têtes tous les jours donc c'est
vraiment très intéressant en local si
j'ose dire de pouvoir faire ce genre
d'atelier pour accéder à la salle de
contrôle interne de contrôle du véhicule
ça tout à fait et si vous tombez bien à
la bonne heure vous pourrez voir sur les
écrans que des excuses ça te passe au
dessus de lui en cours vous lisez
plusieurs laboratoires au sein de cette
mauvaise que je précise juste on va voir
les images qui a également un escape
game qui a proposé est du côté du ls que
vous lisiez ans et laboratoire des
sciences du climat et de l'environnement
avec sa grande car au texte un escape
game qui est proposée ce samedi vous
retrouvez tout le programme sur le site
internet de l'ot vs cul et dimanche le
programme va se refermer avec une grande
journée portes ouvertes à l'aube est ce
que c'est ça de 10h à 18h donc là a pas
besoin de réserver vous venez en famille
il y en aura pour tout le monde les
petits et les grands on a quatorze
ateliers différents
on a du spatial du climat de l'arctique
on a des choses numérique des jeux vidéo
on a aussi des choses plus classiques on
peut mesurer le co2 dans une pièce on a
un atelier aussi de qualité de l'air
c'est à dire essayer de comprendre un
peu mieux dans nos maisons ce qui se
passe quand on ouvre un dissolvant quand
on fait le ménage en bas des choses très
technique il y en a pour tous les goûts
il ya quatorze ateliers et c'est un
classique d'accueillir aussi ce public
pour cette fête de la science j'imagine
que du côté de aux questions les plus
tôt compte andré accueillir ce public a
eu forcément c'est moi contraints par la
crise sanitaire de confinement on n a
pas fait l'année dernière
malheureusement on était elle en était
très malheureux donc la dernière fête de
la science elle date d'il ya deux ans
maintenant on est vraiment très très
content on espère vraiment accueillir
beaucoup de monde on a suivi aussi
récemment l'actualité de l'eau vs qu
alors il ya on a parlé du vs cussac y
avait aussi une autre actualité c'est la
mission persévérance qui a atterri sur
mars en février ses 18 février dernier
le latmos a travaillé sur l'outil super
calme il ya une actualité autour de
santa fe il ya une grande conférence qui
aura lieu demain donc dans le cadre de
nos conférences habituelles de
l'observatoire et dans le cadre de la
fête de la science donc c'est ouvert aux
classes il va y avoir des classes qui
seront là demain c'est une conférence
qui a lu à 12h30 à l'observatoire s'est
ouvert à tous
là on peut dire que persévérance va
commencer quand même à pouvoir nous
donner des premiers résultats enfin tout
cas les premiers résultats dont on va
pouvoir parler au grand public donc
c'est franck mommessin un directeur de
recherche au latmos qui va tenir cette
conférence demain midi donc vous en avez
parlé ce programme ouvert à tous alors
ça dépend il ya des ateliers qui sont
pour les 6 12 ans emery est ce que c'est
sur inscription quand même même si c'est
s'est ouvert au public aux 6-12 ans vous
parlez de la conférence de demain la
conférence de demain ou même le
programme d'animations
demain là on est jeudi soir donc pas de
soucis on vient on sera accueilli aucun
problème samedi il faut bien sûr
s'inscrire puis à la sécurité des
insolents qui est en jeu et dimanche on
s'inscrit pas on vous accueille
directement à l'accueil de
l'observatoire et comme on a quatorze
ateliers qui dure 30 minutes chacun bien
sûr il va falloir choisir en fonction de
vos envies du temps dont vous disposez
de l'âge de vos enfants si vous en avez
et c est là on va vous faire vous
proposer un programme rien pour vous et
donc ce programme on le retrouve sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci annabelle doazit n'êtes
rien je vous en parlais en plateau
chargé de communication pour sauver ce
qu l'observatoire vote c'est
l'observatoire je vais y arriver de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines une
fête de la science je vous disais à qui
a lu vs qu l'université versailles saint
quentin va se dérouler jusqu'au 11
octobre un programme complet également
au programme avec des visites aussi
insolite l'institut lavoisier de
versailles le gmac également un groupe
d'étude de matière condensée qui est
bien à vous accueille pour des visites
insolites ou le programme un jour disait
sur le site internet du vs qu
[Musique]
au chapitre politique le premier tour de
l'élection municipale partielle à
trappes les électeurs sont appelés aux
urnes après l'invalidation du résultat
du scrutin de 2020 et parmi les quatre
candidats en lice luc miserait pour
trappe à gauche l'ancien conseil
municipal était sur le marché de la
commune hier pour rencontrer les
habitants le reportage de céline charles
et de patrick jacques de dixmude
trappe à gauche la liste conduite par
luc miserait est en campagne à quelques
jours du premier tour de l'élection
municipale partielle le candidat
distribuer des tracts pour présenter son
programme au trappistes la candidature
qu'il propose est une alternative de
gauche proposé dans une optique
d'apaisement on a souhaité donner une
alternative de gauche on a des tas de
personnes qui nous disent heureusement
vous est présentée s'annonce on serait
pas allé voter il ya des gens qui sont
un petit peu lassé de des polémiques qui
aimeraient et c'est bien légitime qu'on
parle un peu plus de leur problématique
à eux trappe à gauche s'articule autour
de douze priorités de la revitalisation
des quartiers à la jeunesse et
l'éducation en passant par un travail
sur la pauvreté nos propositions
concrètes c'est
travailler sur la revitalisation des
quartiers c'est à dire remettre de la
présence humaine dans les quartiers
c'est travailler sur une véritable
démocratie c'est à dire mieux associer
les gens sur l'éducation un plan massif
pour la formation des animateurs au
premier tour de l'élection municipale
partielle de 2020 attrape le taux
d'abstention était de 65 90 %
face à ce constat luc miserait affiche
une volonté invité au vote comme il ya
eu beaucoup de caricatures de notre
ville ça incite pas forcément les gens à
aller voter et donc nous ce qu'on essaye
c'est de redonner confiance et de leur
dire vous pouvez avoir confiance en des
gens qui sont là depuis des dizaines
d'années la gauche elle est diverse et
ben vous avez le choix c'est l'objet du
premier tour et qu'après au deuxième
tour bien on souhaite que cette ville
bien évidemment reste à gauche le
premier tour de l'élection municipale
partielle aura lieu le dimanche 10
octobre prochain un éventuel second tour
est programmé pour le 17 octobre
c'était notre fil rouge cette semaine la
rédaction mettait en lumière le plan en
france relance et surtout la manière
dont il a bénéficié aux yvelinois et
dernier numéro ce soir consacré aux
collectivités direction chevreuse la
communale a bénéficié d'une subvention
de 500 mille euros pour son projet
d'éclairage public les précisions dans
ce sujet de mélanie poquet de patrick
jacques de dixmude
bientôt la fin du simple allumage et
extinction à chevreuse les 1000 points
lumineux de la commune vont s'adapter
aux besoins en éclairage liées à la
sécurité et à la circulation avec cette
totale rénovation la commune pourra
choisir notamment l'intensité de
l'éclairage on est en train de créer un
groupe de travail technique dans lequel
on associera les gendarmes pour aspect
sécurité le parc naturel pour l'aspect
environnemental et puis certaines de
techniciens et quelques élus et on va
travailler sur le plan de la commune en
lift en en ciblant différents types dax
on envisage à partir de cette
cartographie de différencier les
périodes c'est à dire alors je vous
donne un exemple je sais pas si on
s'arrêtera cet exemple là mais sur un
axe très circulé on fera peut-être
qu'une baisse d'intensité dans la nuit
de 30 ou 40% par exemple pour remonter
vers 5-6 heures du matin en fonction des
usages un projet pensé par la mairie il
ya un an d'un montant d'un million
d'euros cent cinquante mille sont
financés par la région ile-de-france le
projet est aussi soutenue à 50% par
l'état la commune a obtenu un
financement de 500 mille euros du plan
france relance dont on est vraiment au
début du dispositif puisque c'est un
marché qu'on a lancé l'année dernière
et sur lequel dès le départ l'état a
souhaité nous accompagner dans la
première vague finalement des projets
qui ont été soutenues dans le cadre de
france relance ce financement du plan
rentrer dans la dotation de soutien à
l'investissement local pour financer les
grandes priorités d'investissement des
communes et leurs groupements
ce renouvellement permettra à la commune
de faire une réduction de 60 % de sa
consommation d'énergie on le sait tous
un le prix de l'énergie ont flambé
je pense que même si les dates sont
annoncées au printemps prochain on ira à
long terme de toute façon pas sur une
tendance baissière au niveau de la
facture ça va pas se répercuter petit
mais ce qu'il faut se dire c'est que si
on était resté sur l'ancien système de
on est pas une récurrente et c'est notre
consommation auraient augmenté
de de manière forte 80 collectivités
territoriales dans les yvelines se sont
vus attribuer des fonds de france
relance d'un budget de 100 milliards
d'euros sur deux ans 30 milliards de ce
plan sont dédiés à la transition
écologique
avant de vous laisser un atelier bd et
cinéma il était proposé ce mercredi à la
bibliothèque de viroflay une vingtaine
d'enfants a pu y participer en compagnie
d'un invité de marque et xavier
giacometti scénariste et réalisateur de
yakari est la rencontre est un avant
goût du festival de la bande dessinée
qui va se tenir ce week-end à buc célia
gars de son go et gabrielle gauthier
c'est ce qui fait la puissance de la bd
à la bibliothèque de viroflay une
vingtaine d'enfants ont assisté à un
atelier bd et cinéma présentée par le
dessinateur et réalisateur de yakari
depuis 17 ans xavier giacometti chaque
année la bibliothèque nos fils de
girofle à un partenariat avec le
festival de bd de buc et donc on reçoit
un dessinateur ou un scénariste bd qui
propose en a tenu pour les plus jeunes
plutôt à l'aise avec l'univers de la bd
les enfants de 7 à 12 ans connaissait
tous yakari je lis yakari je lis
si tu entends que c'est très bien et
nous expliquer comment passer d'un d'une
bd un film après la bd nous expliquer
des croquis les différentes étapes de
coloriage c'était bien j'ai bien aimé
comment il expliqué on commence à voir
qui ont été faits des films comment
procéder faire la bd il alla
objectifs de cet après midi là pour le
réalisateur montrer l'envers du décor
les enfants gardent beaucoup de dessins
animés peut-être certains lisent
beaucoup de bandes dessinées mais il ya
un aspect que les enfants ne connaissent
pas c'est le tout l'aspect un peu
cuisine fabrication secrets de
fabrication et et ça c'est intéressant
la partager je leur montrais pas des
choses m'ont rigole voilà donc il quand
on regarde des certaines images que j'ai
montré qu'ils sont des choses qui est
nous l'autre quotidien dans le travail
et qui est la réalité de ce métier là
ils ont quand même été je pense qu'il va
leur en restait quelque chose mes films
il ya carrie la grande aventure sera
projeté en ouverture du festival de bd
dubuc vendredi 8 octobre à 20h30 au
théâtre des arcades de buc en présence
de xavier giacometti
et regarder yakari a tenu à saluer tv 78
et ses téléspectateurs on remercie
xavier giacometti pour ce dessin qui
fera donc l'ouverture de ce festival de
la bd qui sera présent tout le week-end
pour des dédicaces et rencontres au
château de buc un festival ce 9 et 10
octobre voilà c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de votre fidélité demain vendredi
place aux 7,8 week end j'aurais le
plaisir de vous retrouver en compagnie
de bixente mais rien senti steban un
point sur l'actualité des idées aussi
pour se divertir samedi et dimanche dans
les yvelines rendez vous vendredi dès
18h belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]